[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous pensez des transports en
commun de parisiens plus tôt
par ben ça va plutôt agréable à prendre
tous les jours voilà votre sort elle
aime quoi je n'ai pas de soeur salue on
prend pas les transports sinon ce que
tout le temps en temps au défilé karl
lagerfel un temps été 2004 et alors
qu'est ce que ça fait qu'est ce que vous
pensez des transports en commun
parisiens alors je pense que ils sont
importants par rapport à d'autres villes
en europe et votre sol en pense quoi
j'en sais rien en tout cas moi je prends
le vélib
parce que c'est quand même on aimait
libre exactement couleurs
on est les petits de michou quelle belle
soirée new browser
ah ouais ok c'est lui la coupe du sein
salut bonjour ça roule c'est quoi c'est
la téloche
je regarde pas on préfère bucci des
paint à ce qu'ils nous sortent un peu
des sentiers battus go
ce trail tout bison futé enfin sorti on
parle du bus je pense quand même qu'on
n'a pas grand chose à reprocher sauf que
évidemment dans les rues embouteillées
ils sont soumis il ya il devrait y avoir
des allées spécifique des en a mais il
ya souvent aussi des gens qui
stationnent etc et qui gèle les
transports il veut que ça alors on pense
quoi franchement vous croyez vraiment
qu'on connaît au prince transports en
commun franchement montois ne me lancez
pas sûr courchevel j'en reviens c'était
une horreur
là j'ai des choses à dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]